MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
JAN: Welcome to Google Apps
Script Office Hours.
I'm Jan and this is Eric.
Just a note before
we get started.
If you're in the Hangout,
join with us.
In just a few minutes we'll
actually bring you in.
We're trying out something
new today.
So if you're in the Hangout
right now, you probably won't
be able to actually participate
for a few more minutes.
So what we're going to cover
today, we answered a few
questions on our
moderator page.
We can take some live questions
from those of you in
the Hangouts, and then we're
also going to do some quick
little reviews of some of the
web apps created with Apps
Script that we've come across
in the Chrome Web Store.
OK, so Eric, do you want to get
started with the questions
that we have in Moderator?
ERIC: Yeah sure, so Office
Hours, for people who are new,
this is a time, really, for us
to just talk about Apps Script
as well as answer
your questions.
So if you have questions during
the week that aren't
getting addressed, feel free
to bring them up right now.
And the Moderator here is for
people who can't make it live
or just don't feel like
asking on the air.
So to get started, one of the
ones we have at the top is,
"Is there an Apps Script to
receive email notifications
whenever a collaborator edits
a text document?" That's
definitely one of the things
people use Apps Script for,
doing automatic sending of
emails and interacting with
their Google Drive.
So I think this is right
in the sweet spot
of Google Apps Script.
I'm not sure I've seen
a script that does
this use case exactly.
Have you run across one?
JAN: I haven't seen anything for
a text document-- if, by
that, you mean plain text as
opposed to a Google document.
I'm not sure that we have, for
example, an event today, or a
way to determine has somebody
edited a text document.
It's something we've have a lot
of future requests for.
ERIC: I think the best guess of
what you could probably do
is, using triggers, set up a
trigger that runs at a certain
interval, let's say every five
minutes, and checks the last
edited date, the last updated
date of something in your
drive Using the docs
list service.
If you did that, it's not, like,
the instant they made
the edit, but at least within
five minutes or so you could
probably determine has
it updated since
the last time I checked?
JAN: That's a good point.
ERIC: If you put that together,
I don't think it
would be that much work
to put that together.
And it would make definitely
a good app.
JAN: What I'm not sure is
whether or not you'd be able
to pull who the collaborator was
that made the last edit.
I'm not sure if that's exposed
in the API or not.
But it's worth looking into.
And if you don't need that,
then this technique could
probably work for you.
ERIC: You just need to know
if it changed at all.
JAN: Right.
ERIC: That could work.
JAN: This could work.
ERIC: The next one we have here
is, "I'm trying to use
Apps Script to archive
selected Gmails.
My company doesn't want to
enable IMAP, and so Apps
Script seems like it's a
reasonable alternative.
Can I invoke Apps Script from
a contextual gadget.
If not, is a web service using
Apps Script possible?" So,
have you seen people use
contextual gadgets with Apps
Script before, Jan?
JAN: I don't know that
that's supported.
So I don't think so.
I don't think that the Gmail
contextual gadgets can
currently work with
Apps Script.
ERIC: I looked into
it briefly.
And I think one of the
limitations with Apps Script
today is you can't iframe it
within some other context.
So you cannot create an Apps
Script app and embed it into a
web page or a contextual
gadget.
So I think that's going to limit
a lot of the use cases
for contextual gadgets today.
I think theoretically using the
content service to return
JavaScript, JSON format, that
then some other JavaScript
could parse.
This is like at the fringes of
what's possible, but I don't
know if it's been explored,
really.
JAN: Yeah, that would be that
would be the best place to
look, I think, would be
the content service.
If you're not familiar with
content service, it's a way of
serving up content that is
some sort of, basically,
text-based content.
So it could be XML, it could be
RSS, it could just be text,
it could be JSON, any of
these types of things.
So you can effectively write
your own web service, which is
possibly what you're
looking for here.
ERIC: I think it could
be some things.
It uses redirects, which causes
problems sometimes--
the content service.
Also around authentication, and
making sure you're logged
in when you're making
that request.
I think there are some
challenges there, but it's
worth exploring.
JAN: Yeah.
So, if you're the person who
entered this question and you
try this out and you run into
any trouble, or you have
things that you wish the content
service could do
differently that would make
solving this problem easier
for you, let us now on
the issue tracker.
Or if you're just having
trouble, let us know on Stack
Overflow and we'll
take a look.
ERIC: That's a great
suggestion.
The next one we have here is
related to ScriptDB, which is
the built-in object store
in Google Apps Script.
They want to know how
unique are the IDs.
So they already asked this
question on Stack Overflow--
great place to ask questions--
and got some guesses from the
community but haven't exactly
got a firm answer.
So uniqueness, I think it's
definitely unique within a
current script or within a
script database, right?
JAN: And we believe it should
be unique, at least the way
that Apps Script works
today, it should be
unique globally as well.
But I can't go so far as to say
I can guarantee that will
always be the case.
So I think you are safe to
assume that it's unique across
that script.
ERIC: Yeah and I think it may
always be a good idea to just
create your own identify
within your object.
So you can use the ScriptDB ID
to get access to that record,
but if this represents a record
in some other system,
or there's some other way of
creating an ID, use your own
ID in addition to ScriptDB ID.
That gives you flexibility in
the future to, let's say,
clear out your ScriptDB and
repopulate it again.
And if you repopulate it with
your custom IDs that you're
maintaining, then you don't
need to worry about things
getting wiped out.
So you may not want to rely
on the ScriptDB ID for
everything, although it can
be useful at times.
So another question we have
here is really to
Google Cloud Connect.
I'm not familiar with
this, are you?
JAN: I'm not either.
My understanding is that it's a
tool that allows you to sync
some of your Google services
with files
in Windows, I believe.
I haven't used it myself, so I'm
not really able to answer
this question, right here.
ERIC: Yeah, so the question
is going into sinking
spreadsheets to and XLSX
and an import button.
The one thing I do know is, we
have had people ask, how in an
Apps Script can I take a file
and convert it into a Google
spreadsheet.
Like take an Excel document
and it into a Google
spreadsheet.
That's possible in the Drive
UI, but I don't think it's
possible via Apps Script.
It'll do the upload, but it'll
stay in its original format.
It won't convert it.
The conversion process I
don't think we expose
in Apps Script today.
JAN: Yeah, not programatically.
So if you have questions
specifically about Google
Cloud Connect, my suggestion
would be to try to find the
support page or support link
from the Cloud Connect--
wherever you downloaded
that tool.
That would probably
be your best bet.
Off the top of my head, from
the Apps Script side, I'm
really not sure.
ERIC: Yeah.
The next one we have here is
someone using what I'm
assuming is the UI app
to build a form
with multiple fields.
And they want to collect
up all of that
data into an array.
And they before were using some
sort of method based upon
the name attribute, but
now it's not working.
Is there a fix planned?
Well, I'm actually
not familiar with
this specific problem.
Have you come across
this one yet?
JAN: Not this one.
For the person who entered this,
if you can link us-- if
there's something in the issue
tracker related to this.
Or if there's not, if you could
raise one, that would be
really helpful for us to go back
and try to correlate this
with anything that our engineers
are looking into.
So there's the name and the ID
attribute you can use in
different scenarios to identify
the different widgets
on a form or a panel or
things like that.
And they each serve a slightly
different purpose.
If they're not working,
we definitely need
to know about that.
And I guess the question is--
ERIC: How do you collect
multiples at once.
JAN: I see.
ERIC: Because I think we've seen
things where, like, check
boxes, I think, typically, in
HTML, you name them the same
but then give them
different values.
And then when you're collecting
up, that name
contains an array of
all the values.
That's kind of I feel like
this person is doing .
JAN: Right.
I think we need a little more
details about what you're
trying to accomplish.
This would be actually
a really good
one for Stack Overflow.
If you can give us some of the
code that you're using, and
what's not working, we can try
to point you towards a
solution that will work.
I know that it can be a little
challenging to figure out an
approach to handle the
dynamically added elements
when you don't already know all
the names of the elements
on your form before it's
actually submitted.
But there are solutions
to that.
So we can point you towards
those if you give us a little
more details about what
you're trying to do.
ERIC: That's a good point.
This is the last one I think
we have here today is, "I
would like to know the
direction and plan on
expanding or growing ScriptDB."
Well, ScriptDB is
certainly growing usage
on its own.
I think just the fact that it's
launched and its useful
as we've seen people
start to go do it.
I don't know if we have any
other specific plans for
growing it.
JAN: So basically we have a
roadmap for the plans of
things that we want
to add to it.
It's not really in a form
that we can share
publicly right now.
One thing I do want to point
out is if you have specific
requests, things that you'd
like to see in ScriptDB,
things that you want--
basically, if there's certain
areas you would like us to
focus on, please
do let us know.
And the issue tracker, the
feature request there, are the
way to do that.
That's definitely the best
way to get to the ears
and eyes of our team.
So do let us know.
ERIC: Yeah, for sure.
I think one of the areas that
I've heard some people already
say they want even more power
with is querying.
So to query ScriptDB today uses
a model called query by
example, where you pass in a
partial object that you want
your results to match against.
And I think today, for instance,
you can't do
substring matching.
So give me all of the objects
where the field name contains
the letter A. You can't
do that kind
of "contains" operation.
It has to be either equal
to A or not equal to A.
JAN: Right, so like "like,"
and "contains" and
those types of things.
ERIC: Yeah, things that if
you're using SQL, you may be
familiar with today.
So I think some of those kind
of gaps have already been
identified and are ones that
we're already tracking.
But if you have even more
of those, that'd be
great to let us know.
JAN: Yeah.
ERIC: And it looks like we had
another question or two come
in since I was chatting.
So one that we have here is, "Is
the session variable now
available to access user email
from non-domain accounts?"
JAN: So without trying this,
just off the top of my head, I
think that if you have an app
that is published as a web app
in the way that it is executing
as the user rather
than as the developer, then I
believe you can get access to
the username, email
of that user.
ERIC: That's correct, yeah.
JAN: That's correct?
OK.
ERIC: I think I tried that
recently just to test it out.
JAN: And the reason that it's
allowed, in that case, the
user is actually presented with
some information when
they install that application
that lets them know that this
is something that's possible
so that they can choose to
authorize that application
or not.
So that would be the one case
where for a non-Google Apps
account, you can access
that information.
ERIC: Yeah, I think that's
something that people have
been wanting for a long time.
You know, who is this user
running my application?
And now since they are presented
the opportunity to
say yes or no to this app, it
allows you to get a little bit
of extra information.
JAN: Yeah, So this can
be really powerful.
ERIC: That's great.
All right, I think that's all
the questions we have in our
moderator so far.
What do you want to
jump to next?
JAN: Let's jump first to-- well,
I want to run through a
couple of like mini-reviews of
some of the web apps we've
come across in the Chrome Web
Store that were built using
Apps Script.
And then we can use the
remaining time for any live
questions that we have.
So what I'm going to do is
probably just run through
these briefly.
I'm not going to actually run
the apps themselves in the
interest of time.
But I'll just show you four, and
then if you want you can
check them out yourself
in your own account.
So [INAUDIBLE], first of all,
this one is one-- if you've
watched the Google I/O videos,
or if you were at Google I/O
for our sessions, DriveBy is
kind of a sample application
that we talked through
in the presentation.
So what it is is basically a
way to keep an eye on your
Google Drive.
So if you have a shared folder,
and you want to know
whenever a collaborator has
added files that shared
folder, you can choose to watch
this folder in DriveBy,
and it will notify you with
email alerts anytime a
collaborator adds a file
to the folder.
ERIC: It sounds almost all
similar to that question we
had about watching for document
changes, except this
is more like folder additions,
I guess.
JAN: Right, so instead of edits
to a file, it's files
added to a folder.
But it's the same
kind of concept.
We've also have a lot of
requests to have the source
code for this [INAUDIBLE]
published.
Something that we're
working on.
So stay tuned.
I think we'll try to add that,
probably, in our tutorial
section or somewhere like that
so that, if you want to see
how this app was created,
you can do that.
JAN: Next one we have
here Gmail Meter.
So for some reason I'm not
showing the video here.
There should be a video when you
look at the overview page.
Gmail Meter has actually been
around for a while it's been
in the script gallery and it's
kind of gotten a lot of
attention on its own.
It's a really fantastic tool
for-- basically, on the first
day of every month it will
create an email that has all
sorts of charts and
stats about the
email that you receive.
So it's specific to your
own inbox in Gmail.
And I really enjoy using it.
Because I like stats and numbers
and I like to take a
look and see who am I sending
email to, and who is sending
email to me. and all of
those sorts of things.
So I find it really useful.
ERIC: I think it's a great
example of something that was
in the Google Apps Script
Gallery, which is something
that's only usable in Google
Spreadsheets, being promoted
to, really, becoming a full
web app in the web store.
This is not really a
spreadsheet-based sort of script.
It's not there to manipulate
cells, it's actually
it's own web app.
And before, it was kind of
limited to that box.
But since we have now the
standalone scripts and the
Chrome web store, it's really
allowed scripts like this to
become their own powerful tool
separate from Google
Spreadsheets.
JAN: So as a developer, this
[INAUDIBLE] developer of this
web app a lot more.
It's more easily discoverable
because you don't have to be
within a Google spreadsheet
to find it.
And it's great for users
too because they can
all check it out.
And you can install it.
When you install these, if
you're not familiar with the
Chrome Web Store, you'll get an
icon on your new tab page.
Or you can also just launch
it directly from here.
ERIC: If you're out there and
you've written a really
awesome script in the script
gallery, it may be worth
taking just the half day it
takes to kind of convert that
into something that's
appropriate for the Chrome Web
Store, and get a lot more
eyeballs on it, a lot more
useful functionality
out of it.
JAN: Yeah, because there are
quite a few scripts in the
script gallery today that aren't
really just spreadsheet
extensions, if you think
about it that way.
Some of them are, and some
things are custom functions,
or some things need to be a
menu on a spreadsheet, but
there's plenty of things which
could easily be ported over to
a web app and published in
the Chrome Web Store.
And if that's the case for
something you've written, we
strongly encourage
you to do that.
I think it's a great
opportunity.
So moving on.
So Gmail Print All for Chrome.
This is another one
that I like.
So what this does is it will
take a label that you've set
up in Gmail, and then it will
basically get all of the
messages from the threads, I
believe, and add those into a
document and put it in
your Google Drive.
So it's a way to kind of get all
of the messages from all
of the emails under a label, put
them in a document so you
can easily print them out or
just save them in that kind of
long format for some
other purpose.
ERIC: Yeah, I think as the
developer listed here, to do
that in the UI, it's--
every thread, print, go.
And I can imagine, like,
let's say you
are planning a wedding.
It's go time, today's
the wedding.
It would be helpful to have
every bit of communication on
hand in one document that you
could just refer to make sure
that all the details
that you've
planned out are actually--
JAN: Yes.
ERIC: Actually working.
So I think sort of like this,
really, is powerful.
JAN: And for travel
planning for me.
Like when I have a trip, and I
have my hotel reservation, and
I have all of this stuff.
I may not even need to print it,
but I want it all in one
place where I can just pull
it up and glance.
It's kind of useful
for that too.
The final one I want look
at, I actually just
learned about this one.
So Drive forms, this is
really interesting.
So this allows you
to build forms.
And it's not a Google
Spreadsheet Form, it's a
separate kind of form, using a
template that you create in a
Google document.
So you would create this
template that kind of is like
a merge template.
Then you would create the
form using this web app.
And then you can send it out,
and it'll send it out to
whoever you choose to email
it to you in PDF form.
So that's also a
pretty useful.
And again, it was created
with Apps Script.
So these are some cool
ones to check out.
Have you used this one?
ERIC: I remember trying
it out once.
I haven't actually used it
in a real-world scenario.
But I did try it out.
And I was impressed at how
powerful it is at reading in
the different placeholders
that you have on your
document, and creating
form fields for them.
It's really very
nice that way.
It's kind of along the same
lines as mail merge.
Some of the mail merge scripts
people have seen
and used in the past.
But now it's standalone, and
it works primarily around a
document, which I think
is a great way to kind
of hold your template.
Other mail merge scripts have
you embedding it in the source
code, or putting it in a
spreadsheet cell, but actually
creating a full Google document
is a great way to
allow you to do all the
extra formatting you
would want to do.
JAN: OK, so now I think we can
jump over and take any live
questions that we might have.
ERIC: All right.
JAN: OK.
ERIC: Hello Hangout.
Do we have any questions in
the Hangout, feel free to
unmute and ask away.
MALE SPEAKER: Please can
you open your chat?
I think we have posted
some questions there.
ERIC: Ah, some questions
in the chat.
Unfortunately we're not
allowed into there.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
good working, thank you.
ERIC: Sure, all right, well
one second, I can log into
that chat in just a minute.
We're trying a new format here
today, which means that we're
going to have little bit
technical difficulties.
But I think, so far, it's
been going well.
JAN: So while Eric's logging
in to see the chat, does
anyone else have any questions
they want to ask live?
And then we'll jump
over to the chat
in just a few minutes.
MALE SPEAKER: I guess maybe
I can ask directly.
Do you have any news of the
Google API form issue.
JAN: I'm having a little
bit of trouble hearing.
I can try to mess with the
volume a little bit.
Can you ask that again
just a bit louder?
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry it's
maybe my microphone.
MALE SPEAKER: I can
hear you fine.
ERIC: Yeah here, can
you ask us again?
JAN: Yes, it's better for me.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm wondering if
you have any news from the fix
you said you've done for the
Google API form issue.
ERIC: The Google
API form issue?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, you know the
process form function who
doesn't work?
ERIC: Yeah, OK, yes, I know
what this is referring to.
So if you're using the HTML
service and you want to take a
form that you have and submit it
back into your server-side
scripts. it used to be possible
to take the whole
form element and just
pass it back.
And that unfortunately, this
week or last week, broke and
throws an error.
So I know the engineer who is
working on that, and it's
something that's definitely
in the pipeline.
And that should be fixed
really soon.
It should be coming out
within hopefully the
next couple of days.
We've been looking into some
workarounds and there's not a
great ones at the moment,
especially if
you're uploading files.
But it shouldn't be too
much longer, we hope.
MALE SPEAKER: I have
a question.
Many of the scripts that I've
written are asking users to
input HTML.
Just curious is the rich text
editor ever going to work, or
are there plans or even
a way to present
users an HTML editor.
JAN: So I think our
recommendation, there was
actually something in the
issue tracker about this
fairly recently--
the rich text editor in UI app,
it would be extremely
complicated to get that
up and running.
But what we are recommending
is instead to
use the HTML service.
There are quite a few
jQuery-based rich text editor
solutions that you can do.
And those should work fine.
So that's kind of our
recommended solution there.
Is that if we want to have a
rich-- sorry , that's really
hard to say--
rich text editor in your user
interface that you're building
with Apps Script, would be a go
with HTML service instead.
MALE SPEAKER: I guess the issue
that I've encounters is
that Caja is very fussy.
And so I'd love to see an actual
worked example before
investing dozens of hours to
discover that Kaha strips out
some essential piece of code.
JAN: OK, that's a totally
fair suggestion.
And maybe that's something
that we can
actually look into.
Since there's multiple people
who are looking to be able to
do rich text editors.
So we'll take a look at that
and see if we can put
something together.
I also want to mention that if
you run into issues with Caja,
I've found that the team that
works on that-- it's an open
source project-- but the team
that works on it is very
responsive.
I've raised some issues there
myself and I find that they
jump on them pretty quickly.
So we'll take a look at that
and see if we can get an
example of one of the many
JQuery-based rich text editors
working in HTML service.
And if we can, we'll update
here, or I'll update, maybe
we'll add it as a tutorial
or something like htat.
something like that.
ERIC: Yeah, this is a note.
If you're new to using the
HTML service, Caja is the
project that sanitizes and makes
sure that all the HTML
that's being served is safe
and not malicious.
But sometimes it can be
a little restrictive.
And some libraries that you
may pull out from the web,
certain JavaScript libraries, it
may not be compatible with
them right now.
Definitely some more
investigation to be done.
JAN: They definitely do support
JQuery and JQuery UI.
So if what you're using is just
using kind of, plain,
vanilla JQuery, you
should be OK.
But again, we'll try
it out ourselves
and see what we find.
ERIC: Definitely.
So I didn't get the chat open
here, unfortunately since I
wasn't in the Hangout out at
the time that the chat
questions were asked,
I don't see them.
So you can either ask your
question on chat again, or if
you feel like reading it
out loud, feel free.
Oh, we have some typers here.
Got a pretty full Hangout
today, too.
JAN: We do, yeah.
ERIC: Thanks everybody
for coming out.
All right, so we've got a
question here from Andy.
200 MB ScriptDB is too small
for business edition.
JAN: OK.
My question to you in
that case would be--
what size would you want.
This is something you'll find
us asking a lot with some of
our quotas and limits.
Is if it's the limits that we
have in place today don't work
for your needs or for
your use case--
let us know, ideally in the
issue tracker, as in this case
a feature requests
would be best.
Let us know what amount you
think you would need, and
what's the reasoning
behind it.
So it doesn't have to be your
very specific business case.
But what sorts of data
are you storing.
Why is this amount too small and
what amount would you need
to see you have this be a
viable solution for you.
So we take that sort of feedback
really seriously.
And that helps us improve
the product.
so do.
You open up something in the
issue tracker for us on that.
And if anybody else has
similar feelings
towards it, chime in.
We want to get the most
representative set of use
cases possible.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MALE SPEAKER: Being a billable
you made a comment there,
billable one.
It might be interesting to see
if it's possible to tie your
scriptd database size
to your Drive size.
And therefore, if you can do
that, then by buying larger
Drive size, you can pay
for the added storage.
JAN: That's an interesting
idea as well.
ERIC: It is.
And something I was going to
mention is that I think part
of understanding ScriptDB and
working around its limits, is
understanding what it's good
at and what it's meant for.
So if you're trying to store
image data or binary data in
ScriptDB, it's really more
meant for our JavaScript
objects, kind of like records
in a database--
large pieces of blog content
are probably best stored in
Drive using the Docs list API
and things like that.
So I think if you're reaching
200 MB on just little pieces
of script data, then that's
a real case that we
need to look at.
But if you're trying to store
files in ScriptDB, that's not
really, I think,
its sweet spot.
And you may want to look using
Google Drive and the Docs list
service for that.
JAN: Right.
ERIC: And we had a question
there from Marcus.
How can you implement Gmail
function on a WebApp?
So if you've mean using
the Gmail service,
it should be possible.
If you want to actually
implement something that acts
like the Gmail UI, I'm
not sure we can
to answer that here.
It definitely takes a lot of
manpower to create the Gmail
UI, so it would not be
easily replicated.
But the basic tools for
interacting with Gmail are
there in the Gmail service--
getting threads,
sending emails.
JAN: Right.
ERIC: And you could do that in
any form of script, whether it
be a web app or something that
runs on our trigger.
JAN: Right, so one clarification
to make if
you're trying to use the Gmail
service in a web app, there
will be a difference depending
on how you publish it.
There's two ways that you
can publish web apps.
We kind of alluded
to this before.
So when you go to deploy
something as a web app,
there's a selector that says
run this, execute this as--
and you can execute it as
yourself, the developer--
probably not what you want to
do in this case because that
would be your inbox.
Or you can publish it so that
executes as the user who's
accessing the app.
And that is generally what you
want to do in the case that
you're using Gmail because you
probably want the user to be
able to do something with their
own Gmail inbox rather
than yours.
So just something to
keep in mind there.
ERIC: Definitely, when creating
a web app, always
test it using a secondary
account.
JAN: Right, make sure it
behaves how you expect.
ERIC: Make sure it behaves
how you expect.
That answers that question.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I had a
runaway script last night.
ERIC: Oh really?
[LAUGH]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah I used i
twice as an iterator, and so
it just went.
And it timed out.
Fortunately I had it
on a demo account.
So it threw the error, and I
can't send any more email
through that one account
anymore.
Until tomorrow.
JAN: Until tomorrow, yes.
ERIC: It's a good thing
to demo things on a--
to have to have a development
account to work on in case you
blow your limit.
JAN: Yeah, that is
a good idea.
ERIC: It looks like Andrew had
another question here in chat,
do you want to ask
it live, too?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah I guess I'm
trying to figure out, in
approaching the web app
framework, given that most of
my scripts at this point have
been built in those
container-bound scripts, what
are the exact limitations?
Are there things that
I just definitely
can't do in a web app?
JAN: Yes.
So one thing that a web
app can't do that a
spreadsheet-bound script can do,
since those are, I think,
the ones that you're probably
most familiar building.
So in a spreadsheet-bound script
you have this notion of
active spreadsheet
and active sheet.
And there is not that automatic
notion of an active
spreadsheet in the case
of a web app.
If you had spreadsheet data you
wanted to access, you'd
have to do open by ID and give
the spreadsheet ID into the
web app before you could
then access ranges or
anything like that.
So that's one thing
that is different.
Another would be, you can't
do, basically, any of the
spreadsheet-specific things.
So browser.messagebox or adding
a menu to spreadsheet--
because there's no
spreadsheet.
Things like that you can't do.
But then there's a lot of things
that it opens up to you
that you wouldn't be
able to do in a
spreadsheet-bound script.
ERIC: I think part of, maybe,
how you can make the decision
is thinking about what
your script does.
Is it primarily there to
modify and operate on a
spreadsheet?
Or is a spreadsheet either not
part of the script at all, or
maybe just an input to the
script, and you'd want that to
work on any number of
spreadsheets, right?
So if you have some sort of
script that you may want to
run on 100 different
spreadsheets, rather than
install it 100 times, you could
create one web app that
had a picker that allowed you to
pick which spreadsheet you
wanted to operate on
at that moment.
And then kick off the rest of
the process from there.
So it's really, I guess,
thinking about is this
primarily a spreadsheet
experience, or is it
primarily, maybe some others
sort of standalone experience.
JAN: Yeah, that's kind of
how I think of it too.
Is it meant to extend what a
Google spreadsheet can do?
Or is it just the fact that
when you created it in the
past all app scripts were
spreadsheet-run scripts So now
that we have these standalone
scripts, it's not necessary
for all scripts to be bound to
a spreadsheet or Google site.
They can be standalone and you
can publish them as a web app
if that works for
your use case.
MALE SPEAKER: And are there
restrictions on things like
storing user data
in a web app?
Like if I had ScriptDB running
and I want to actually create
a user table that had
user-specific settings in it.
Are there any restrictions
against that?
JAN: So there are not.
One thing to note is with
ScriptDB, regardless of how
you publish your web app,
whether you publish it to run
as you the developer or as the
user accessing it, there's
only one DB for that script.
So you have to do some work
yourself to figure out how you
want a silo that data, how do
you want to identify this is
the data for this user versus
this is the data for that
user, but that's just
kind of up to the
design of your program.
You'd want to structure in such
a way that you would be
able to identify, oh, these are
the settings for this user
versus that user.
And since, if you publish these
web apps to run as the
user, you'll be able to get
the identity of the user.
And so you can actually
key the data into
ScriptDB that way.
I hope that answers
your question.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool,
thanks a lot.
ERIC: I think are just
about out of time.
JAN: Oh, we are, I
didn't realize.
ERIC: It went by so
quickly today.
JAN: It did.
ERIC: All right, great,
well I mean, I think--
I don't see any more questions
in the chat.
We did get a thank you from
Marcus and wondering if we'll
come to the Philippines
anytime soon.
It's not on my travel plans, but
maybe we can work it in.
JAN: Well I would love
to, we'll see.
We'll keep on our
list of possible
future hackathon locations.
We'll see what we can do.
ERIC: Well, thanks everyone
again for coming today.
If you have any questions we
didn't get to, feel free to
either add them on Stack
Overflow, where the whole
community can pitch in, or chuck
them on the Moderator
And we'll take a quick look at
them after the broadcast.
JAN: And then we'll hopefully
see some of you next week.
And next week will be 4:30 PM
Eastern time next Thursday.
ERIC: All right, great.
JAN: Thanks everybody.